we've talked about neural Anatomy we've
talked about neural chemistry the last
bit is neuro electricity so what we now
know happens in flow is our brain waves
which are kind of normally in waking
consciousness up in beta this is a
fast-moving wave it gets really excited
and you go up to and kind of into stress
responses right it moves down to alpha
which is a daydreaming mode and then
below that is theta theta is only
accessible in the hypnagogic status
we're starting to fall asleep or in
dreaming and REM sleep flow takes place
on the border between alpha and theta it
just kind of hovers there so it's a
radical change in normal brain function
but something else really really cool
happens so we talked earlier about how
creativity is enhanced and flow one of
the other ways that is enhanced is when
you're on the border between alpha and
theta because you're in theta you can
get a gamma spike gamma is coupled to
the theta wave it's a very fast-moving
wave and it only shows up when ideas are
coming together when we have that aha
moment right that's a gamma spike gammas
coupled the data so it can only show if
you could only get that aha moment if
you're in data and flow by pushing us to
the borderline between alpha and theta
sort of sets us up to have massive
startling with insights
you